this is mine a restaurant in Arkansas  has come up with a solution to that  age-old problem men know this women on a  date saying I'm not really hungry and  then they help themselves to your meal  diner we like your mama D's diner in  Arkansas they call this dish my  girlfriend is not hungry entree so it  adds fries to chicken wings or three  fried cheese sticks to the entree  they've been working on this for many  time for a long time and now it's just  gone viral and the menu option mama Dee  says has solved most of the couple's  problems listen I definitely plead  guilty to this and I'm not aware that  people don't like it when you eat off  their plate don't you want me to taste  my son's plate last names yeah I find  that some people actually think that's  irritating yeah I just think that's  friendly sharing yeah and also I'm  paying for the meal I think I'm sort of  entitled conversation here I sometimes  don't want to eat that much I'll take it  off the katys plate